ich befürchte wir befinden uns am anfang
der wahrscheinlich größten
fluchtbewegung in europa seit ende des
zweiten weltkriegs wir erleben dass in
berlin im besonderen natürlich berlin
für die kriegs geflüchteten aus der
ukraine das tor zu westeuropa ist wir
sind ja jetzt seit rund drei wochen auch
in vorleistung gegangen für die gesamte
bundesrepublik haben quasi als kleine
stadt als kleinstadt land die menschen
aufgenommen und dann uns bemüht eine
bundesweite verteilung erst mal
selbstständig und auf freiwilliger basis
in die wege zu leiten und jetzt sagen
die große herausforderung die ich mein
team die ehrenamtlichen erleben ist im
folgendes man hat es einerseits jeden
tag mit sehr großen zahlen zu tun die
mit vollen bussen vollen zügen
schubweise ankommen bis tief in die
nacht und sogleich hat man es nicht nur
mit großen zahlen zu tun sondern mit
ganz konkreten menschen die alle auch
schreckliche geschichten haben als es
kommen viele alleinreisende mütter mit
kindern inzwischen auch mehr mütter die
noch andere kinder mitnehmen weil die
eltern nicht fliehen können aber sagen
dann nimmst du noch die freundin vom
kind mit die kinder an teilweise ein
haustier mit das ist das letzte
überbleibsel von der heimat was man
eigentlich nach veterinären
gesichtspunkten erstmal waren thema
schicken kann über werden ein kind schon
den hasen weg nehmen was gerade ein
vater zurückgelassen hat im
schützengraben wir haben zunehmend mehr
menschen mit behinderung
pflegebedürftige also das sind menschen
mit ganz besonderen bedarf mit ihr eine
besondere unterstützung brauchen und
zugleich seine großen mengen und dem
gerecht zu werden das zu organisieren
und dann auch jeweils die individuellen
bedarfe zu sehen das ist eine verdammt
große herausforderung und wir tun das
alles in dem wissen dass wir erst am
anfang sind also vor uns liegt noch ein
marathon und wir laufen gegen tagen
sprint und über sie sprechen mir aus der
seele ich warne vor
oder seit wochen eigentlich schon darauf
vor seit kriegsbeginn davor dass wir es
hier mit einem massenphänomen zu tun
bekommen und das berlin wahrscheinlich
dass einfalltor zunächst mal ist man
auch der tatsache geschuldet sein berlin
zwar arm aber sexy meine frage
wäre meine zeit für meine frage ist
jetzt an sie konkret was hat denn der
berliner senat als er als er gemerkt hat
wir kriegen hier ein problem ein
mittelschweres problem nicht nur am
hauptbahnhof sondern in ganz berlin
unternommen der bundesregierung
gegenüber
und an hilfen gebeten beziehungsweise
konkrete maßnahmen von der
bundesregierung gefordert wie man diese
zuströme kanalisieren und letztendlich
auch in den griff bekommen kann
also wir haben ein großteil meiner
arbeitszeit und energie aber auch von
anderen senatsmitglieder auch von der
regierenden bürgermeisterin ist auch da
drauf gegangen wirklich dem buch den
bund wachzurütteln und zu sagen leute
wir haben es hier wirklich mit einer
grossen flucht bewegung zu tun und es
werden womöglich noch mehr kommen wenn
der krieg weitergeht wir haben
persönlich angerufen zum hörer gegriffen
haben letztlich auch in amtshilfe
ersuchen an die bundesregierung gestellt
haben in den verschiedensten schalten
immer wieder darauf hingewiesen
es gibt hier ein problem ich weiß als
ich schon in die öffentlichkeit gegangen
wir haben hier wahrscheinlich einfacher
größten fluchtbewegung hat das bank noch
erzählt in den medien naja sind doch
bisher nur 5000 gekommen da hatten wir
schon am bahnhof im hauptbahnhof in
berlin jeden tag 10.000 ankünfte also da
haben wir sehr viel unternommen ich muss
sagen zum glück ist der bund jetzt auch
wach geworden und es beginnt jetzt
hoffentlich die verbindliche bundesweite
verteilung an diesem wochenende wir
mussten das teilweise über brücken und
haben bilateral mit anderen
bundesländern uns verständigt um das
hinzubekommen aber die ganze situation
wurde natürlich dadurch erschwert dass
wir das system der doppelten
freiwilligkeit haben also wir können
zwar die leute registrieren aufnehmen
und dann entscheidet das sehsystem in
welches bundesland kommen die aber die
anderen die aufnehmen bundesländer sind
frei zu sagen wir schicken die wieder
zurück haben sie ihren chef in folge mal
ganz vorsichtig den tipp gegeben dass
die bundesinnenminister in der gleichen
partei angehört da braucht überhaupt
kein tipp also muss sagen wir haben uns
ja erst jetzt in den letzten monaten
kennengelernt aber vgh hat von anfang an
dem brisanz der lage erkannt hat sich
unglaublich ins zeug gelegt und hat
profil hat die verschieden ja ich bin
jetzt nicht die regierungssprecherin der
bundesregierung genau nicht in der spd
aber ich kann nur sagen die regierende
bürgermeisterin von berlin hat sich echt
ins zeug gelegt und hat auch permanent
die verschiedensten anrufe getätigt und
schritte in die wege geleitet um den
bund zu sensibel hiermit was von
herausforderung wir es hier zu tun haben
integration der stellvertretende
vorsitzende polizeigewerkschaft sie
wissen also genau wo es bei der polizei
brennt wie die polizei bad aussieht wenn
sie es hören die herausforderungen vor
der bestehen ich habe eine ganz
pragmatische frage darüber mein letzten
tagen viel debattiert können sie
eigentlich beziffern wie viele der
ankommenden flüchtlinge ukraine sind
nein wir können nur das beziffern was
wir feststellen im rahmen der der
momentan schleierfahndung also
überwachung der grenze zu polen mir
liegen zahlen vor die sind jetzt immer
bei 200.000 seiten flucht beginnen und
da drunter ungefähr zwölf bis 15.000
nicht die ukraine das sind aber alles
keine repräsentativen zahlen weil wir
wie gesagt an unserer an unserer
eigentlichen kernaufgabe momentan noch
auch durch die gleiche bundesregierung
gehindert werden wir werden ist nie
schaffen aktuelle zahlen zu erheben das
geht höchstens retro grad war ja die die
die menschen die kommen aus der ukraine
die freiheit haben gottseidank sich in
deutschland wo auch immer registrieren
zu lassen das heißt werden immer tage
wochen unter umständen sogar monate
vergehen bis wir genau wissen wie viele
menschen sind nach deutschland gekommen
dann wissen wir noch nicht mal genau wer
also das ist eine hochdramatische langen
ich kann nur daran erinnern ich hatte
ich hatte bereits im herbst auch in
diesem in diesem kreis gewarnt vor der
vor der entwicklung gerade was die was
die fluchtrichtung aus belarus angeht
und es ist bitter das ist wirklich
bitter dass bis heute offensichtlich
eine unbelehrbarkeit unserer
bundesregierung davor herrscht und
schlichtweg fachexperten aus dem bereich
der bundespolizei nicht gehört umso
erstaunlicher ist es dass die
bundesministerin dem spiegel jetzt in
der neuen ausgabe gesagt hat ist ein
sechs prozent nicht ukraine unter den
ankommenden wenn man weiß dass nur
stichproben kontrolliert werden ist die
hochrechnung auf präzise prozentzahlen
mathematischen ziemliches kunststücke
und sie hat von 10.000 doppelstaatler
beziehungsweise nicht ukraine
angesprochen also aus einer stichprobe
präzisen zahlen hochzurechnen finde ich
eine sehr interessante geschichte ich
habe so ein bisschen den eindruck dass
da
eine falsche fährte gelegt wird
selbstverständlich könnte man
registrieren müsste man allerdings an
den grenzen auch kontrollen einführen
und die müsste man von der eu
ratifizieren lassen was allerdings wohl
in der gegenwärtigen situation kein
problem wäre wir bleiben jetzt auch
direkt bei dem thema was das wenn sie
auch gleich vorstellen hergatz worin sie
polizeilich unterstützung braucht oder
warum sie einfach ihre arbeit machen
welch wird aber vorher noch einmal ganz
kurz gerne zusammen kirsch alten paul
wir sprechen neben flüchtlinge die
kommen es gibt aber auch menschen die
sich klar entscheiden sagt mir bitte
wenn ich falsch liege dass sie in kiew
und in der ukraine bleiben werden
was hat es damit auf sich wie viele
werden bleiben und wie viele werden
kämpfen bis die lage vor ort und wurde
beispielsweise auch schon energie
rationiert in kiew
das ist wirklich das besonders
erstaunliche muss man sagen auch heute
wieder gab es einen schweren angriff in
einem wohnviertel
auch eine schule ist ein kindergarten wo
mehrere kinder verletzt wurden mehrere
menschen verletzt wurden ein mann ist
gestorben und ich war dort in einer
völlig zerbombten wohnung bei einer frau
ludmilla heißt sie hat mir gezeigt wo
sie normalerweise geschlafen hätte zum
glück waren sie an dem abend bei ihrer
tochter im keller und hat sich vor
diesen angriffen geschützt deswegen war
sie noch am leben und hinterher habe ich
sie gefragt warum bleibt dir eigentlich
hier warum setzt ihr euch diesem risiko
aus und die frauen die dort standen die
haben mir gesagt warum sollen wir gehen
das ist unsere stadt und so lange es
irgendwie möglich ist werden wir hier
bleiben was sollen wir denn in
deutschland wo sind wir denn dann da wo
wir sind wir untergebracht nein wir
wollen hierbleiben und viele haben
einfach aus sorge um ihre verwandten um
die eltern um die kinder die ganz
klassischen dinge ich glaube solange
eine stadt nicht so aussieht wie zum
beispiel mario pohl oder eine stadt
nicht so aussieht wie ihre pin oder
buttstädter sind die vororte von kia
fonds auch ein dauerbeschuss gibt die
menschen werden versuchen immer weiter
hier zu bleiben ist noch zwei millionen
menschen in kiew vor dem krieg waren es
fast 4 witali klitschko sagt die zahl
der leute geht er nach oben und die
sozusagen männer die ihre frauen und
kinder in den westen gebracht haben
kommen jetzt zurück um die stadt zu
verteidigen
das ist tatsächlich etwas erstaunlich
ist dabei ist wird sich natürlich ändern
wenn es hier weitere
flächenbombardements gibt also wenn
wladimir putin noch mehr flieger
einsetzen würde wobei die luftabwehr in
kiew zum beispiel besser ist als in
mario pohl auch die raketenabwehr aber
wenn er wenn ich jetzt mal mario pohl
mit aleppo vergleiche wenn man sagt das
sind 80 prozent der zivilen gebäude
zerstört wenn er ähnliche szenen krk
machen würde dann gäbe es natürlich auch
eine massenflucht von daher müssen wir
alles alles tun um wladimir putin
davon abzuhalten mit noch steht aus
meiner sicht mit noch stärkeren
sanktionen
mit mehr waffenlieferungen wir haben
jetzt gerade gelesen eine meldung aus
der welt am sonntag dass von den
versprochenen hilfslieferungen den
versprochenen waffen aus deutschland
nicht mal die hälfte geliefert wurden
und das sind so dinge wo man sich dann
schon an kopf hast und denkt ihr redet
die ganze zeit über die ukraine aber
beim umsetzen und der tatkraft davon zu
hits nicht